[Music]
i like the idea that queen elizabeth
needs to stay like a little bit racist
it's kind of that kind of makes sense
though yeah
it's on brand yeah on brand to maintain
that you know the culture and then
maintain the culture yeah what do they
do if if queen elizabeth was like super
woke she would tear down everything
because everything's built on
colonialism right so then we need a
little bit of colonial whole foundation
would be make it done let putin blow it
up
blow it up leave it in leave it out i
mean he's really just can leave it in
it's really just giving it a good rinse
yeah
a cleansing if you will nice baptizing
ethnic cleansing okay don't ask me
when
because i don't know that's all i gotta
say okay
two one action so there's a man
who
we gotta give it up to the guy he is
currently one of the three winners
in a primary and he's going to appeal
uh up here on this year's ballot for a
township board seat in indiana so let's
go hey congrats
congrats young man i don't even know
what he just said what the hell he's
talking about only problem is he he
murdered his wife
this
how did that you caught us into an
applause right before that well no you
you know
you guys gonna clap after the wife can
accomplish things
and it's like okay well that you could
drop that but they probably don't drop
that
this just shows that canceled culture is
not real you know
everybody gets forgiven neither is
neither is murder culture
let's bring that back you know if he can
he can do that you know we can say some
crazy [ __ ] on here yeah i bet the
prosecutor's not trying to prosecute
that's what's happening
nice joe nice job
uh so yeah he he is 39 years old he's
awaiting trial for the murder of his
wife um uh elizabeth wilhoit
and he was arrested in march and he he
is um yeah he's going to appear on the
ballot for this board seat but how's his
polling numbers like really really
strong okay cool to me this is a guy who
goes through with his plans
he
so many people talk about killing their
wives and never do it this guy did you
need to be a political publicist follow
him a spin doctor
yeah that's true damn you you want to
see real change vote for this man
all right this guy's a campaign manager
yeah he's the man he'd be so good on a
pr team like one day and he's he steps
down and resigns after one day
after the next death so nothing prevents
you from being able to run huh i mean i
don't know it's pretty interesting how i
think honestly there's just some names
that are on the signs and people like i
like that name it looks good
it just like sounds like a good
wholesome name yeah killer mike
killed everybody what's his name
wilhoe
[Laughter]
it's just i'll kill you
i'll kill you dot dot dot i'll kill you
how did you just [ __ ] murder his like
opponents it's all straight to the point
hey nice
will hoyt get straight to the point i
really don't think there's anything
boring that because even in my hometown
of downey there was like someone who's
on the city council and then they found
out that she was previously like
convicted of embezzlement like something
so clearly you shouldn't be on the
council
and then she was like well i didn't have
a right i didn't have i didn't need to
disclose that legally oh she's got a
point like what this just shows
everything's made up dude that's like
letting a [ __ ] pedophile be a
kindergarten teacher you can't even wait
there probably are there probably are
out there they're like i don't have to
disclose that and they're like you're
right you're hired that's what happened
welcome that's happened to that mayor of
the city of bell um where he would drive
so bell's kind of like a pretty run-down
city and he would drive to
city hall in a ferrari it's not that bad
and everyone just ignored it like what
the [ __ ] how does this guy afford
ferrari and then i think after years
they're like hey maybe we should look
into this maybe yeah
his salary was a million dollars
a million not just him the people around
him too they were all just stacking cash
in that whole weren't they hiring fire
family members and [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
the bell scandal was [ __ ] wild but i
love that this cat shows up in a
lamborghini and he gets out and he's
like i'm the [ __ ] mayor
you know i mean he's like how to get a
lamborghini uh it's because i'm the
[ __ ] mayor
i love this guy
i think i could see that dude
and he's like ask me how much i make a
year he's like
you have to afford this
i mean that kind of makes sense it's
like not surprising right it's uh if you
make more than the president and you run
a city a mayor though you don't know the
president doesn't pull those things down
yeah but officially officially april
500 yeah something like that 400. but
this guy was on paper like you could
look through like the city budget that
means he just did a better job not a
great city either that is not a ferrari
city he's just a hot heart negotiator he
played hardball
yeah he's just got a good agent
that's a nice little race dude yeah well
they do the asian thing you know the
city down the street they're offering me
2 million
[Music]
down the street
that's how you play it there like come
back come back come back because you're
my friend i'm gonna give you a deal
come back
only for four years after four years no
more okay
but because you're my friend when me and
nicky were moving into our place our
we're like trying to lowball the the
owner and [ __ ] and
uh the person next door
starts selling their house like the day
after we start low ball and we got the
lowball even harder because they their
their price was like way lower so we're
like thank you thank you thank you and
my neighbor was like yeah dude he was
like i just went in there and went uh
because he knows real estate people he's
like i'm just gonna low ball the [ __ ]
out of them because i know that this
house has been sitting on the on the
thing for so long yeah and dude thanks
thanks to my neighbor for that so that
was always a little ball you guys
always i get that deal uh but this the
details are unfortunately less
less fun than the headline and and all
that [ __ ] right so three candidates
could win the nomination
uh only three candidates ran so all
three won
they ran unopposed um so he just ran and
like and he just got it yeah
that's crazy
yeah but in america he might win win
right because we like crazy people we do
yeah
you like entertaining people we do right
trump was so entertaining oh he's a
[ __ ] riot dude he's his crowd work
comedies can learn from him how he
rallies
his delivery well even arnold
schwarzenegger you can't even understand
him we still voted for him yeah cause
he's a terminator
because he's a riot do you remember when
he said he's like uh great davis has a
hole so big in this budget i could drive
my hammer through it
and we're like that
and hummers were hot bro
that's all we care about we want that
line yes if it wasn't like his last
thing he's like i'll be back and it was
like oh
yeah that's from the movie the actual
terminator
he goes away he's like
that's
oh
even democrats forgot they were democrat
and they started voting for him well
dude everyone loves the terminator
because the terminator is bipartisan
right didn't he get his uh he's made
pregnant or something yeah yeah he did
yeah what another term dude one again
and you know what he said to his mate
after that he said hasta la vista
and she's like that's spanish [ __ ]
love that guy
because my label dude trying to believe
it jesus christ isn't there someone we
know that hangs out with his son that is
the son of the maid
oh
yeah
the illegitimate yeah he looks just like
arnold but mexican yeah like a crazy
like mexican wear jawline that's how
maria schreiber found out cause she's
like this guy this guy looks exactly
like my [ __ ] husband
and he's like coming over to the house
with his mom and [ __ ] dude oh my god
his genetics are too good bro you can't
like i know they're too dominant man
yeah if you have a buff ass kid with a
square like [ __ ] jawline you gonna
know who it is
you ever see that video of arnold
schwarzenegger you ever see that bit of
arnold when he's liking it from his
documentary he's talking about working
out he's like the pump i get he's like
it's better than coming that's what he
says all the time it's better than
ejaculation i guess it wasn't in this
case
different kind of pumping you love
arnold over there yeah i realized
what's your favorite arnold movie oh
what's the one with the get to the
chopper one what is it what's left oh
yeah
competitor yeah incredible very good
very good uh do you
what do you think the
malaysian
and british stereotype might be of the
us and our politics oh
guns guns and fat people
i mean the uk is pretty fast well if
you're standing longer we should we
should take you out to go shoot have you
shot before no i would love to oh yeah
oh yeah we all love guns i love the
ideas of god that's good yeah dude yeah
check this out
do you think we're stupid do we look
stupid like when you guys are viewing it
from over the ocean do you guys look man
those guys are dumb
no i don't i don't think they got good
vision though
i'll tell you right now on
we think you guys are [ __ ] smart as
[ __ ] really no we believe anybody with a
british accent the whole world's dumb
it's just you guys are louder so if
people realize you guys are dumb quicker
you know in the uk they're dumb too they
just don't say [ __ ] so we you think
they're smart but then you talk to them
like holy [ __ ]
this is always what it comes down to
though the office uk versus the office
u.s
that's where it's game over which one's
better i've never even seen the office
office burma is the best
for me's office so good [ __ ] good man
is it yeah do they have the same uh
theme song no it's under dispute
currently
is it just the american office in
brownface
[Laughter]
so what's that what's the best american
stereotype and then what's the worst
best american stereotype the girls the
girls the girls beautiful perfect teeth
oh
that's american thing huh it's it's nice
man seriously you go to the uk holy okay
so that's true that is a bad stereotype
of the uk why do you think that is i
mean dental work is more yeah
probably adds to it i think dental work
is more common here everybody wears
braces growing up right it's prioritized
yeah they're just not concerned about
that type of thing oh they don't care
and now i'm starting to do invisalign
now because i'm on camera so much i'm
like oh let's fix that to fix that [ __ ]
so i wish i grew up here would have
better teeth you know yeah that's the
best stereotype i guess you guys have
royalty in a way that i mean we have
royalty like we have the kardashians you
guys have like [ __ ] royalty though
like railroads do you guys like actually
look up to those people yeah yeah yeah
no one really gives a [ __ ] huh no they
don't care like
malaysia
uh malaysia we have royalty to malaysia
don't care about that either really i
would say at least the royalty malaysia
and the uk they're not like annoying you
know you see kardashian on instagram all
the time you don't see the queen taking
a selfie by the pool or something i
think that could elevate her brand i
wish they did
i hate how classy the royals are because
if i had the title of a king
dude i'm gonna be [ __ ] louis the 14
mean that [ __ ] i'm gonna be so
flamboyant dude wearing [ __ ] gold
capes every day
i'm so rich what are you gonna do about
it isn't that the classy part that you
hate they don't do that anymore that's
their ancestors that were so new money
and they're wearing the [ __ ] like
golden robes and stuff and they're just
like i'm so rich i need to build another
building that's what deontay wilder does
mm-hmm nigel what do you guys what does
the uk people think of my favorite
prince prince andrew
wow he's my personal favorite yeah we
love him
everybody loves a pedophile over there
that's so american now you know why
that's his favorite
it's it's it's good i mean
sometimes i wish we were successful
enough to be a pedophile
it's a stereotype they're all successful
people who own an island
and we should encourage them because you
know we always talk about climate change
and stuff right so what a better way to
fix the climate than to talk to the
pedophiles because it affects the people
they love most that's true the children
so they're going to recycle they they
would care the most they should be in
charge yeah exactly you are a good
campaign manager
for one day that's outside the box
thinking that i think this world
my client yes he's a pedophile but he
don't point at me the weather yes
let's put him and greta in a room
together to come up with some ideas
oh my god
i bet michael jackson recycles that's
all i'm saying
oh